hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played a few months
ago uh it's a game between two world
champions current uh or rather reigning
world champion being living in classical
chess and the former World Blitz
Champion Alexander grishuk who won the
world Blitz Championship in 2012 and
2015 and since Bing didn't do all that
great uh I mean the the bar of course
was set high for for a reigning world
champion in the classical event that he
just played in in Bucharest he got
eighth place out of ten
uh you guys requested the to show a nice
game they're being played so this is a
Blitz game against Alexander grishock
who is an exemplary Blitz player also
gets in time travel quite a lot uh let's
check out what happened in this one and
the white so uh so awesome so ding has
the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 he goes for the ready
opening we have Knight F3 G3 D5 Bishop
to G2 and pawn to C5 now uh the
so-called Sicilian variation against the
king's Indian uh we have castles and now
uh Pawn to G6 we've D4 C captures on D4
Knight captures and Bishop to G7 bit of
a rare setup uh Agri shook is going for
but it has been played before of course
we have knighted the B3 C4 is the top
move here uh ding wants to play sort of
a sideline with Knight to B3 castles
Knight the C3 now putting pressure on
the D5 pawn and Sasha just defends it
with E4 Knight to C6 and E captures on
D5 and Dean knows this position very
very well he even had a in a classical
event against Michael Adams and he won a
very nice game there in 2019 in
kazakhstanakstana
uh but in the game he captures and D5
was played here Grisha continues with
Knight captures on D5 and now alireza
tried Knight to the E4 against karwana
once and he only got a draw there but
here we have Knight captures on D5 and
it is now as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game so here he captures
on D5 and now Pawn to C3 this is a
beautiful move because it controls D4 it
controls the Knight on C6 it controls
the bishop so uh grishuk decides to get
rid of the pawn C captures Knight
captures and now Bishop to E3
threatening to win the Knight here so
Knight back to C6 you could also capture
on B3 but then
um he uh Queen trade is avoided and Dean
will continue to have pressure against
the blacks Queen side so instead Knight
back to C6 and now Knight the C5 and
this is a tricky move by ding because it
sort of offers a complete trade down if
uh Sasha once he could trade everything
like captures Rook captures on D1 Bishop
captures on B2 not The Rook attacks the
bishop or even better Bishop captures a
night capture some B7 first which would
force The Bishop's on the B file then
Rook the B1 end if you want to save the
bishop pair you have to play Bishop D6
attack the rook and F1 Rook after D1 and
now let's say Bishop to C3 and now you
regain your peace with Bishop captures
and then the rule comes to B8 to DH to
see it or whatever wherever you want but
um yeah it should be it should be okay
uh instead after a knight to C5 Queen
the E7 was played and okay ding plays
Rook day one puts the rook in front of
the queen we have rooked the d8 now
attacks dings Queen and dingo's queen to
B3 we have Queen to C7 getting the queen
out of Harm's Way off of that e file and
now Rook 8 to C1 ding basically finishes
his development and the Sasha can't
really find an active move here he
should play something like Ponte H6 but
he played Queen to B6 and now ding's
position is winning but you have to play
a precise series of moves so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the ding's idea while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
beautiful maneuver and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
night captures and B7 and here uh when
ding played it everyone thought okay he
just wants to uh pick up the uh the pawn
and later on he's gonna cap run C6 so
Sasha believed him he played Queen
capture some B3 uh the only way to
continue this is actually to play Queen
capture some B7 then you play Bishop
captures and C6 then Queen captures on
B3 and only after you trade you move the
Rook from the A8 square and narcos
Bishop to G5 but still this will be very
very hard to survive for black but he uh
ruined his position completely after
this Knight captures on B7 will he
played Queen captures on B3 but now ding
does not recapture the queen he plays
Knight captures on d8 and he leaves the
the queen on B3 just B and uh you know
what can Sasha play here he has to move
the queen he can capture on B2 he can
cap Ronnie do he decides to capture on
B2 but now ding just plays Knight
captures on C6 he wins even more
material and the problem also for uh
grishock is that the ding has well uh
well around two minutes on the clock and
she has some 20 minutes on the clock and
yes this is five plus one so you do get
the one second increment after you play
a move and that can be quite a lot since
this was played online uh it's still not
going to be easy with Bishop to B7
because how do you meet the thread of
knights the E7 check just winning the
rook and A8 uh Bishop to B7 was played
uh but now Rook the B1 the only winning
move but uh ding finds it attacks the
queen we have Queen to C3 and now of
course none of you are considering Rook
captures B7 because the rook and E1 is
hanging so Rook eat the C1 and it was in
this position on move 23 that Alexander
grishuk resigned to the Game ending won
a brilliant brilliant Victory by
sacrificing none other than his most
valuable piece the queen so here you
resign because uh once the queen moves
and you have to move the queen you're
just gonna capture on B7 and you have
too much for the queen you have a light
Square Bishop a knight and a rook for
the queen and that's simply too much
material of course the Alicia cannot
contest this especially with so little
time on the clock the problem is let's
say Rook to f8 there are even moves like
Bishop to D5 and now black is without a
move for for the rest of the game pretty
much and you can't capture the bishop
because of Knight to E7 check just
winning the queen back so uh not a lot
to do for Sasha here so of course after
this um uh rookie to see one move Sasha
resigned and a brilliant brilliant
victory for uh dingler and or in you
know in those days the the future world
classical Champion the ingleren uh so
yeah while ding had a a tough event uh
he's he will now play the rapid and
Blitz tournament in Poland we'll see if
he bounces back strong in that one or is
it simply not enough time it starts in
some three days so uh stay tuned until
that at that time and if you guys have
any other suggestions that you would
like me to cover just use hashtag
suggestion in the comments and I will go
over that game so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it a very nice
miniature by by the classical world
champion Dean liren I would like to
thank Mazi and Elsa rag ding fan
revision reptiles YouTube and Blake
tarot for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing uh to check
up on everything else that's happening
in the Chess World uh and your wonderful
suggestions as I usually do so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day